polémique en italie ou un gynécologue a
implanté dans l'utérus d'une mère
porteuse deux embryons issus de deux
couples différents la prochaine
naissance de ces vrais faux jumeaux pose
évidemment beaucoup de problèmes d'ordre
éthique mais aussi juridique valérie
gagés jusqu'à présent les jumeaux qu'ils
soient vrais ou faux étaient toujours
frères et soeurs mais cette loi
naturelle est en passe d'être contredite
en italie de couples stériles ont eu
recours à la fécondation in vitro les
deux embryons obtenus sont donc
génétiquement très différents mais ces
deux embryons ont ensuite été implantés
dans l'utérus d'une troisième femme une
mère porteuse
enceinte de 12 semaines elle devrait
accoucher en septembre de deux enfants
qui après des tests sanguins seront
rendus à leurs parents respectifs
le gynécologue italien qui a pratiqué
l'intervention dans une clinique suisse
n'y vois aucun inconvénient
nous avons affaire de bébé qui vivent
dans deux sacs différents avec deux
placenta différents qui sont nés de deux
ovules et de deux spermatozoïdes
complètement différent donc ne
souffriront pas être si on peut imaginer
qu'il y a dans l'utérus de la mère des
relations qui se passe entre les deux
enfants et dont on sait pas du tout
comment elles vont devenir ou ce que ça
va entraîner pour l'enfant une fois que
la séparation se fera après la naissance
ce n'est pas la première fois que ce
type de polémique éclate en italie en 94
une femme de 62 ans qui avait perdu son
fils dans un accident avait pu avoir un
deuxième enfant grâce à une fécondation
in vitro très tardive
hier le ministre italien de la santé a
réclamé une réglementation urgentes en
matière de fécondation assistée et de
clonage